une journée en montagnes russes pour
l'observatoire du mont mégantic ce matin
le conseil d'administration annonçait la
fermeture pure et simple
fin mars du plus important centre de
recherche en astronomie du canada en
cause un problème de financement de 500
mille dollars par année liée à la fin
d'une subvention mais en après-midi le
fédéral a promis une aide financière
pour garder l'observatoire ouvert au
moins deux ans mais christian paradis
ajoute qu'il faut un plan de
développement à long terme pour éviter
de revivre continuellement ce genre
d'épisode le directeur de l'observatoire
est avec nous en les noyant bonsoir
bonsoir alors d'avoir votre réaction
devait être soulagé quand même un sursis
de deux ans oui absolument
je suis prêt à soulager et ça manque
tout l'ouverture de notre gouvernement à
maintenir nos activités dont mais bon
comme vous l'avait bien dit le problème
demeure entier je suis d'accord avec mes
super a dit qu'ils vont alors devoir
trouver une solution alors que c'est ça
la solution à long terme un financement
récurrent le voilà donc historiquement
l'observatoire est là depuis une 178
donc on a pendant 17 ans a reçu des
subventions du gouvernement fédéral de
manière récurrente pas garanti je
souligne fallu renouveler nos
subventions ils ont toujours eu beaucoup
de succès pour le faire le problème
c'est que ces programmes là n'existent
plus donc il n'est plus moyen de pouvoir
financer de manière récurrente notre
infrastructure et donc vous avez vu
cette subvention de 500 mille dollars
par année il ya deux ans et là c'est ça
qui était en concert c'est un peu plus
compliqué que ça season nous avons eu
une subvention pour par hasard mais par
une subvention de la fondation
canadienne des livres de l'innovation
ce permis de pouvoir mettre à niveau
notre notre observatoire ou s'il faut
des instruments pour d'autres des scop
ou quelques ardeurs accès et dans cette
subvention il y avait des fonds pour
maintenir notre notre futur une utilité
de cette subvention spécifique qui était
alors qu'ils quittaient seulement pour
un projet ponctuel et limité dans le
temps on aurait été forcé de fermer
alors il ya eu une levée de boucliers
aujourd'hui
vous avez été témoin mais rappelez nous
pourquoi c'est si important
l'observatoire pour la recherche
scientifique
l'observatoire est unique l'observatoire
du mont mégantic c'est un lieu d'art de
formation unique au canada c'est le seul
observatoire en milieu universitaire et
souci le seul qui ait aussi bien
équipées de nos équipements n'ont rien
arriver à dire que ce qu'on nesta sur
les grands télescopes pour la simple
raison que une bonne partie des grands
instruments combien sont l'utilisent
comme les plus grands télescopes qu'on a
accès au canada sont développés par les
chercheurs de l'observatoire du mont
mégantic
c'est là qu'on forme les chercheurs
silva finalement commencé voilà donc on
forme ne nous chercheurs chez nous mais
c'est aussi une plateforme de
développement instrumental de nouvelles
technologies qui sont ensuite exportés
vers les grands télescopes pour le
bénéfice de toute la communauté a sonné
canadiens nous un exemple
écoutez moi j'ai eu le privilège de
participer aux grands découverte en en
2008 c'étaient les premières images
l'exoplanète qui a été fait son
télescope de 8 mètres les lits pliants
this qu'avocat leur ont accès mais la
technique d'observation pour faire ça
pour faire des découvertes là à d'abord
été développé dix ans plus tôt dans donc
de l'observatoire du mont mégantic
on pourrait en effet plusieurs comme ça
à notre participation dans le télescope
spatial james webb découle de
technologie infrarouge qu'on a
développée dans don de l'observatoire du
mont mégantic au début des années 90
donc c'est un une écriture qui
extrêmement important d'un point de vue
stratégique pour le développement de la
soul music au canada sur tout le
développement de nos grandes
infrastructures que nous avons
absolument besoin pour se maintenir dans
pole position à l'échelle internationale
évidemment ça une importance très
important pour toute la région
bien sûr on reçoit chaque année 20
milliers de personnes qui viennent voir
nos installations sont fascinés par par
le télescope
c'est aussi une région absolument
magnifique c'est la seule réserve de
ciel étoilé en urbain au monde a envahi
la première donc si on ne réussit en
travaillant avec les partenaires la bad
à maintenir un site qui doit qui crucial
pour pour nos activités et donc oui bien
sûr on
bien qu'hier mais les gens c'est sans
doute l'endroit le plus unique au canada
pour ce qui est de la diffusion de la
culture scientifique
donc oui l'observatoire du point de vue
leur est extrêmement important et ils
ces victoires là bien sûr génère une
activité économique qui est très
significatif pour la région et donc
c'est assez triste en fait que vous
soyez tout le temps obligé de demander
du financement
oui plutôt que de faire de la recherche
c'est malheureusement la réalité de
quelques noms vie bon ceci dit c'est
toujours ça fait partie du travail d'un
chercheur de toujours chercher de l'aide
l'argent je voudrais absolument oui et
je dirais qu'il faut il faut pas donner
de l'argent comme ça sans bilan de
gestion tout ce qu'on veut on veut avoir
accès à des programmes de subventions
qu'on peut obtenir d'une manière
compétitive c'est important c'est comme
ça que la science avance et on ne manque
pas de passe droit je suis content de
savoir de recevoir de subventions de
super a dit aujourd'hui mais je dirais
que dans l'absolu c'est pas la meilleure
façon de faire on devrait être évaluée
par dow perd 61 teralys on devait le
faire je serai très confiant qu'on
serait finance vous souhaitez vous
obteniez un jour ce financement
récurrent merci beaucoup monsieur doyon
je remercie
on